We are following breaking news at five a
person is dead after a shooting happened
on the west side of the valley thank you
for joining us at five I'm Brian Loftis
I'm Denise Valdez when Metro Police
arrived they found one person inside a
home with a gunshot wound now this
happened near the 95 in Jones and Sasha
Loftus has the latest
police are still investigating tonight
after they say A man was shot and killed
at a home here off the dura Avenue right
near Jones and the us-95. officers say
they got reports of a shooting just
after noon today and found a Hispanic
man in his 40s with a gunshot wound who
died here on scene Metro says the people
who own the home are getting ready to
sell it and the victim was a relative of
the owner here working when this
happened police are still searching for
a suspect but say this is an isolated
situation based information I had this
is an isolated incident it appears to be
something connected within this family
that owns the residence and who was
doing work on the residents police say
they are also trying to determine
whether the shooting happened inside or
outside this home and who was here when
it occurred now of course officers are
as I said still searching for the
suspect connected to this and they are
asking anyone with any information to
contact Metro Police or Crime Stoppers
to remain anonymous at
702-385-5555 reporting in the West
Valley tonight social Loftus 8 News Now